Seit einer Woche sind Manu und Jonny
vom Cabaret DivertiMento
.
* Wehmütiger Gesang: "The Lion
Sleeps Tonight" von The Tokens *
Seit einer Woche sind Manu und Jonny
vom Cabaret DivertiMento
zusammen unterwegs -
3'000 km quer durch Südafrika.
Wir erleben zusammen etwas.
Es ist ein konstantes Arbeiten
an dieser Beziehung.
Eine Reise, die wichtig ist
für ihre Freundschaft -
und zur Bewährungsprobe wird.
Was soll das?
Talk english, man!
Das ärgert mich tödlich, tödlich.
Ich will jetzt packen und abhauen,
möglichst schnell.
* Dramatischer Trommelwirbel *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Der atlantische Ozean vor Gansbaai
in Südafrika.
Ich bin mega aufgeregt.
Ich freue mich mega.
Zusammen mit der Crew
spürt man die Aufregung.
Ich bin mega gespannt.
Und die Spannung
hat mit diesem Käfig zu tun.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Was? Ah, da ist einer. Scheisse!
* Dramatische Klänge *
Shit! Shit!
Hast du das gesehen?
Ein Riesending!
Das Riesending
kennt man besser als Weisser Hai.
Vor Gansbaai hat es
besonders viele dieser Tiere.
Manu hat sich gewünscht,
den grössten Raubfisch der Welt
so nahe wie möglich zu erleben.
Du, es stimmt doch schon,
dass man am besten
in diese Taucheranzüge pinkelt,
damit man etwas warm bekommt.
- Jawohl.
Das habe ich jetzt schon getan.
Okay.
Der Käfig
bleibt hinten am Boot befestigt.
Okay, perfect!
Go next to your friend.
How are you feeling?
Awesome!
Aber es ist ziemlich kalt.
- Ja.
Big Mama - 4,5 m.
Der Guide sieht ein grosses Weibchen,
4,5 m lang.
* Alle reden durcheinander. *
In der sog. Shark Alley
leben mehr Weisse Haie
als an jedem anderen Ort
in Südafrika.
* Karibischer Popsong "Under the Sea"
aus Film "The Little Mermaid" *
Die Haie sind gerne hier,
weil es in dieser Gegend
viele Robben hat.
Geil!
Das war ...
Mir fehlen wirklich die Worte.
Thanks.
Viel geiler,
als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Das ist unfassbar. Man schaut ihnen
geradewegs ins Maul hinein.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ich dachte, dass sie ans Boot
gelockt werden, aber so nahe!
Du kannst sie berühren,
aber das darf man nicht.
Auch wenn es an diesem Ort
viele Weisse Haie gibt,
weltweit ist er
vom Aussterben bedroht.
Es gibt nur noch
max. 4'000 dieser Tiere.
Der Veranstalter des Haitauchens
ist lizenziert
und investiert einen Teil der Ein-
nahmen zum Schutz des Weissen Hais.
Das war crazy!
- Das war unglaublich.
Das war wirklich unglaublich krass.
So nahe, das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ich dachte, das sei Fake.
Man sieht in einem Prospekt
das Bild eines bösen Hais.
Ich dachte, man sehe höchstens
einen Schatten vorbeihuschen.
Aber es war so nahe. Echt krass!
Also dieser Traum,
man kann es Traum nennen,
das live zu erleben,
ist mit diesem Ausflug hier
mehr als erfüllt. Mega!
Sein Wunschzettel
hat einen Punkt weniger.
Done!
* Fröhlicher afrikanischer Gesang *
Mit festem Boden unter den Pneus
geht die Reise weiter.
Manu und Jonny wollen dorthin,
wo die Welt aufhört.
Oder zumindest der Kontinent.
* Sentimentaler
afrikanischer Gesang *
* Düstere Klänge *
Letzte Woche sind die zwei
von Kapstadt nach Hermanus gefahren.
Jetzt wollen sie
durch die Halbwüste Karoo
bis nach Baviaanskloof -
mitten in die Wildnis.
* Sentimentaler
afrikanischer Gesang *
Ich will nach Oberägeri.
Grüezi. Oberägeri?
Ja, haha.
Oberägeri. Kann ich mitfahren?
Entschuldigung?
So ein Schafseckel.
Das heutige Tagesziel
ist Cap Agulhas.
Der südlichste Punkt Afrikas.
Allein schon die Fahrt dorthin
ist ein Erlebnis.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Heute ist too much!
Ein Highlight jagt das andere.
Gegen Schluss hätte ich
am liebsten alle 3 Min. angehalten,
um mich hinzusetzen und zu atmen.
Sonnenuntergang.
Weite. Afrika.
Strassenstaub.
Dort steht der
zweitälteste Leuchtturm Südafrikas.
Eben jetzt wurde er angeschaltet und
jetzt beginnt das Licht, zu drehen.
Wir sind
am südlichsten Punkt Afrikas.
So lange es noch Licht hat,
trinken wir dort ein Bier.
Südafrika ist Jonnys zweite Heimat.
Er kommt einmal im Jahr hierher.
Auf dieser Reise will er Manu zeigen,
warum er dieses Land so gernhat.
Sollen wir zu diesem Aussichtspunkt?
Wow! He, shit!
Magisch.
Unfassbar.
Cheers. Das ist krass.
- Das ist mega krass. Mega.
Unfassbar.
Das waren heute wirklich
viele Eindrücke für einen Tag.
Das war heute ein mega
emotionserfüllter Tag, finde ich.
Einerseits ist es immer
die Umgebung, die Natur,
die einfach bombastisch ist.
Das berührt mich.
Ich bin noch immer mega geflasht.
Ich kann das Erlebnis
mit den Weissen Haien
noch immer nicht ganz einordnen.
Das war crazy.
Crazy! Heute ist too much!
Diese Fahrt im Abendlicht vom Shark
Spotting hierher war auch mega.
Mega! Heute ist es echt mega krass.
Wenn jeder Moment deine Vorstellung
um ein 100-Faches toppt,
das ist einfach mega.
Verdammt schön!
* Lebendige Gitarrenklänge *
Ihre Unterkunft haben die zwei
auf dieser Reise immer dabei.
Morgen!
Übernachtet haben sie dieses Mal
bloss ein paar Hundert Meter
vom Strand entfernt.
Das ist er also,
der südlichste Punkt Afrikas.
Hier treffen der Indische und
der Atlantische Ozean aufeinander.
Ein Kraftort.
Das ist wie ...
Was Kraftort?
Nein, das ist kein Kraftort.
Ich weiss doch auch nicht.
Man sieht auch
die zwei Farben der zwei Ozeane.
Wenn man hier geradeaus schaut,
liegt links der Indische Ozean
ganz in Grün
und rechts ist es ganz blau.
Ambiente vom südlichsten Punkt
Afrikas Cap Agulhas.
Wer hier losrudert, landet
4'000 km später in der Antarktis.
Jonny wollte schon immer
einmal Cap Agulhas besuchen
und schrieb diesen Wunsch
auf seine Bucketlist.
Komm, Fischer, komm!
Schau her!
Ich muss es noch
von meiner Liste streichen.
Naturmässig ist es hier ein Traum,
ein Traum.
Weisst du, es gibt Bucketlist-
Sachen, die gar nicht so toll sind.
Aber hier gibt es keine Diskussion.
Das ist auf der Liste.
Und hier stehen wir.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich hatte keine Vorstellung davon
in meinem Kopf,
Jonny hatte eine davon.
Nein, es ist wirklich mega schön,
aber ich habe es mir echt etwas ...
eindrücklicher vorgestellt,
dass man bis
zum letzten Punkt klettern muss,
wo man dann am Ende der Welt ist.
Heute mit diesem Wetter -
hammermässig!
Nein, einfach schön.
Und die Vorstellung,
dass der Indische Ozean
und der Atlantische Ozean
an dieser Stelle zusammentreffen.
Der südlichste Punkt
dieses riesigen Kontinents Afrika.
Das gibt mir ein schönes,
ein besonderes Gefühl im Herz.
* Lebendiger afrikanischer Gesang *
Jungs! Jungs!
Ich stelle kurz auf.
Kommt in 5-10 Min.
Okay, machen wir.
In den letzten Jahrhunderten
ist mancher Seefahrer
am Cap Agulhas gestrandet.
140 Schiffswracks
liegen an dieser Küste.
Jetzt könnte ich klugscheissen,
welchen Wert solche Wracks
aus naturwissenschaftlichen Gründen
haben.
Erzähl!
Viele gesunkene Schiffe
werden nicht geborgen,
weil sie Unterschlupf für Fische
und diverse Meeresbewohner bieten,
aber auch wie dort
als Nisthilfe für Vögel.
Ist keine Umweltverschmutzung,
weil Eisen im Meer steht?
Sicher auch,
aber irgendwann ist es ausgewaschen,
und dann lässt man
die Wracks oft so stehen.
Aha, hast du deshalb im Winter
ein Schiff als Vogelhäuschen?
Das vor sich hin rostet.
- Finde ich toll.
Vor Jonny und Manu liegen
gut 300 km Fahrt Richtung Norden.
Vom Meer durch die Berge
bis nach Oudtshoorn.
Zeit, um in Ruhe zu reden,
die sie seit ihrer Wanderung
durch Schottland nicht mehr hatten.
Im Alltag als erfolgreichstes
Schweizer Kabarettduo
ist der Druck gross
und die gemeinsame Zeit knapp.
Wenn ein Austausch stattfindet,
kommt man immer weiter.
Und logischerweise ist das
auch in dieser Beziehung so,
dass Reden
immer der beste Ansatz ist,
um gemeinsam weiterzukommen.
Manchmal hat man den Mumm,
um zu reden,
aber manchmal lässt man vielleicht
doch etwas anstauen.
Ich denke,
unsere Reise ist v.a. dazu da,
dass wir endlich wieder einmal nicht
mehr jeden Abend lustig sein müssen.
Dieser Druck, jeden Abend,
egal wie es uns geht,
zwei Stunden lang
unterhalten müssen.
Und genau dafür ist es
unfassbar wohltuend.
Weil wir beide
auch total entspannt sind.
Wir sind im Moment nur hier,
um zusammen Abenteuer zu erleben
und nichts anderes.
Und hier habe ich
viel weniger Druck.
Ich versuche, zu lesen,
was dort steht.
Kannst du mir das bitte vorlesen.
Unten steht Shop und oben ...
- Das sehe ich auch.
Ronnies Sex Shop?
Was soll jetzt das?
Und mitten in der Pampa!
Ich wollte zu Mittag essen.
Was wollen wir im Sex Shop
zu Mittag essen?
Was soll das? Ronnies Sex Shop.
He, nein!
Vielleicht heisst
das Restaurant einfach so,
das ist kein Sex Shop.
Dort rechts
hat es einen dunklen Eingang.
Nein!
- Was soll jetzt das?
Wieso hat ein Sex Shop
mitten in der Pampa offen?
Burki, Spielzeug für heute Nacht!
What the hell!
Gehen wir jetzt essen oder
erwerben wir uns etwas käuflich?
Oh!
- Geil!
Hello.
Als erstes
siehst du einen GC-Kleber.
I'm looking for a bra.
Which size do you have?
Muss ich jetzt meine Strings
hier an diese Wand nageln?
Ronnies Sex Shop, das ist ein Pub,
das mittlerweile
zu einer Sehenswürdigkeit wurde.
Das hat wohl
meine Mutter geschrieben.
Es ist die Schrift deiner Mutter,
stimmt.
Hi, my name is Manu.
Is this your shop? - Yes.
Nice to meet you Ronnie.
And that's Jonny. Ronnie and Jonny.
Ronnie ist der Besitzer des Pubs.
Hello Switzerland.
Also there in a sex shop.
Ambiente Ronnies Sex Shop.
* Triumphale Orchesterklänge *
Weisst du,
ob wir hier lang fahren müssen?
Nein!
- Sorry.
Es war ein langer Tag,
und der nächste wird nicht kürzer.
Davon ahnen Manu und Jonny
aber noch nichts.
Oh, la, la!
- Welcome.
Was für eine Begrüssung
nach dieser langen Reise.
Thank you very much. What is it?
- It is Sherry.
This is nice.
Anyone else?
Beim Einchecken wird ihnen klar,
was morgen
auf dem Tagesprogramm steht.
Siehst du,
was wir morgen sehen werden?
Ja, ich habe gelesen,
dass wir morgen fünf
scheue Meerkatzen suchen werden -
frühmorgens 5.45 Uhr.
Das sind Erdmännchen.
Spannend. Ich kriege Hühnerhaut.
Und dafür stehe ich morgen früh auf?
Ich bin heute
den ganzen Tag Auto gefahren,
um fünf scheue Meerschweinchen
zu suchen.
Darf er ausschlafen?
Nein, cool, lässig.
Das Coole ist dieser Bildschirm,
auf dem man etwa 20 Pensionierte
mit Feldstechern sieht,
die in Campingstühlen
um irgendein Erdloch sitzen.
Sie haben Erdmännchen geschaut.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich mag Tiere - und Safaris.
- Ja, ich auch.
Lass uns einchecken. Lässig!
Was hast du getan, Manu?
Es ist jetzt früh am Morgen und
wir gehen auf eine Kleintier-Safari.
Ich sagte Jonny schon in der Schweiz
und gestern Abend,
dass man in einem klassischen
Safari-Outfit erscheinen muss,
was natürlich keiner von uns tut.
Guten Morgen.
Hey, tschau!
Habt ihr eure Ausrüstung mit?
Wir müssen los!
- Komm, es geht los!
Bin ich der einzige ...
* Fröhlicher afrikanischer Gesang *
Jonny, nice to meet you.
Die Motivation, früh aufzustehen,
kann man schon bei mir wecken,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt
mit Erdmännchen-Safari.
Aber ich bin offen für alles.
Das schauen wir uns an. Mal schauen.
Oh, Burki,
das wird ein langer Morgen.
Und ein kalter Morgen.
Es ist knapp 4 °C.
* Grillenzirpen *
Für eine Erdmännchen-Safari
braucht man ein Fernglas
und Geduld.
Viel Geduld.
* Mystischer Klang *
Nach 2 Std. Warten ist es so weit.
Wie er aufsteht.
Ist das geil.
Die sind ja mega klein.
Jesses Gott!
Aufwand - Ertrag?
Selbst für mich als Tierfreund -
na ja.
Wenn ich so früh
aus den Federn steige,
dann würde ich gerne
die Big Five oder so etwas sehen.
Aber es war ganz okay.
Was denkst du?
Ja, weisst du, in diesem Format
kann ich nicht ganz ehrlich sein,
sonst würde es den einen oder
anderen zu Hause vom Sofa jagen.
Ähm.
Es hatte durchaus grosse Momente.
Und genau diese Momente
bleiben ja bekanntlich
für immer in Erinnerung.
* Fröhliche afrikanische Klänge *
Der Tag ist noch jung und
das nächste Ziel nicht weit entfernt.
Es geht nach Swartberge
in die Halbwüste Karoo.
Dort soll der nächste Wunsch
von Jonny in Erfüllung gehen.
Und dieser Mann hat damit zu tun.
Ja, ja, ja, okay, okay.
Hier steht tatsächlich
ein Mann mit einem Anhänger.
Nice to meet you.
- I'm Lindsay.
I'm Jonny. Hi Lindsay.
Hello. I'm Manu.
- Pleased to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
- Yeah, you too.
Hattest du Radfahren
auf deiner Liste? - Moment!
Ich wollte schon immer
in einer Wüste Rad fahren,
aber nicht über einen Pass.
Aber ich habe gelesen,
es sei einer der schönsten Pässe,
ich kenne ihn aber nicht.
Und wir befinden uns hier
in der kleinen Karoo-Halbwüste.
It's also Kleine Karoo here?
Welche Musik
würde zu dieser Radtour passen?
"Eye of the Tiger"?
- Nein, das ist 08/15.
"Das Feuer der Sehnsucht"?
- Ja, das ist schön.
Ja, genau.
Oder der "Ku-Ku Jodel"
von Oesch's die Dritten.
"Welcome to the Jungle"
von Guns n' Roses.
Das kenne ich nicht, aber wenn
du sagst, es sei ein toller Song ...
Das passt
zu einem körperlichen Effort.
Okay, dann tun wir das.
Aber bergab Ramazzotti für mich.
Genau: "Se bastasse ..."
- Ja, genau. Komm, wir gehen.
* Rocksong "Welcome to the Jungle"
von Guns n' Roses *
Auf staubigen Strassen
27 km den Berg hoch.
Der Swartberg Pass ist ein
südafrikanisches Nationaldenkmal.
Aber das macht es für Radfahrer
nicht weniger anstrengend.
Ich brauche
meine Asthma-Medikamente.
Ich ersticke schier.
Jonny ist am Kämpfen.
Nicht gut. Ich hab auch die ganze
Nacht nur noch Wasser geschissen.
Ich läge gern im Bett.
Ich habe heute noch nichts gegessen,
und jetzt bei 28 °C -
das ist nicht lustig.
Sonst brechen wir die Tour ab.
Die Gesundheit first.
Wir können jetzt schon
auf Eros Ramazzotti umschalten.
* Sanfter Popsong "Un'altra te"
von Eros Ramazzotti *
Oder "Atemlos" von Helene Fischer.
* Popsong "Atemlos durch die Nacht"
von Helene Fischer *
* Unverständliche Zurufe *
Genau das wollte Jonny nicht.
Das nervt mich katastrophal.
Ich fühle mich im Moment echt gut,
deshalb nervt es -
vor der ganzen Nation.
Es ist einfach unfair.
Bis jetzt wurde ich als einziger
mit dem Magen verschont,
und heute hatte ich
die ganze Nacht Durchfall.
Es kam nur noch Wasser.
Und jetzt bei 30 °C.
Das ist unfair.
Ich kämpfe noch immer
gegen das Scheissklischee an.
Der Schwule ist nicht fit.
Das hasse ich.
Eigentlich möchte ich
unbedingt zeigen,
dass Schwule auch fit sind
und Sport machen.
Und nicht wegen etwas Kleinem
sofort Männergrippe haben.
Und ausgerechnet in diesem Moment
erwischt es mich.
Das nervt.
* Düstere Klänge *
Er ist in schlechter Verfassung,
weil er heute Nacht Durchfall hatte.
Grosser Flüssigkeitsverlust,
dann wird es happig,
so etwas zu meistern.
Ich verstehe seinen Unmut sehr.
Ein nettes Erlebnis, aber auch
eine Grenzerfahrung, definitiv.
Die letzten 20 m
absolvieren wir zu zweit.
* Dramatisch anschwellender
Orchesterklang *
Das ist die Passhöhe auf 1'583 m ü.M.
Jonny verzichtet auf die Abfahrt.
* Melancholischer Gesang *
* Dramatisch anschwellender
Orchesterklang *
* Monumentale Orchesterklänge *
* Sie redet unverständlich. *
* Drollige Klänge *
Ich bin geflasht und sprachlos.
Jetzt sind wir
in eine Naturzone gelangt.
Auf der anderen Seite des Passes
war es karg.
Und jetzt kommt dieses Bachbett,
grüne Oase, dem Wasser entlang.
Als ich vorher hinunter schaute,
erblickte ich eine Sandbank,
in der ich Tierspuren entdeckte.
Das ist das, was Burki liebt.
Das Natürliche, das Urige, dieses
Ursprüngliche eben, die Natur.
Hammer! Und man begegnet
kaum jemandem. Das ist schön.
Hier mit dem Rad durchzufahren,
ist ziemlich speziell.
Kannst du es geniessen?
- Sehr, obwohl Jonny fehlt.
Das ist mega schade, weil ich weiss,
dass ihm das gefallen würde,
diese Passfahrt runter
in dieses Naturparadies, schade.
* Schrei *
Beschäftigt dich das noch lange?
Oder sagst du:
"Morgen ist wieder gut?"
Morgen ist wieder gut,
heute rege ich mich auf.
Gegen Abend kommt auch Manu im Hotel
unterhalb des Swartberg Passes an.
Jonny kam schon eine Weile
nicht mehr aus dem Zimmer.
Ich kann die Tür
nicht leise öffnen.
Ich bringe sie nicht auf.
Wir lassen ihn schlafen.
Er soll sich jetzt auskurieren.
Mann, ist das schön!
Ich hatte vor etwa fünf Tagen
2-3 Std. einen komischen Magen,
auch den Kameramann hat es
eine Nacht lang erwischt.
Ich hoffe, dass es nichts ist,
das länger dauert.
Ich hoffe, wenn wir ihn schlafen
lassen, ist es morgen wieder fit.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das war ein verrückter Tag.
Fischer schob sein Rad
den Pass hoch.
Respect! Krass, Krass.
Tschau!
Ist schön hier.
Viel hast du noch nicht gesehen.
- Gestern habe ich nichts gesehen.
Das ist verdammt schön.
How do you feel?
Wir sind alle gespannt.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Fieber habe ich sicher keines mehr.
Heute ist eine Fahrt
in die Wildnis geplant.
Weisst du, kennst du das auch,
wenn du lange geschlafen hast?
Ich habe geschwitzt
wie ein Stier und geduscht.
Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl,
alles sei wieder gut.
Aber ich weiss nicht, wie es wird,
wenn wir unterwegs sind.
Es dauert zweieinhalb Stunden,
bis zur Pampa.
Es ist die Frage,
ob wir das tun wollen.
Wenn ich merke,
dass ich kotzen muss, können wir ...
Wenden?
Nein, dort in der Nähe der Pampa
ein Hotel suchen.
Einen Punkt kann Jonny noch abhaken.
Geschafft haben wir es.
Ich habe es mir anders vorgestellt.
Es war nicht so toll,
aber wir haben es geschafft.
Und es hat alles gestimmt:
Rad fahren in der Wüste.
Hätte ich gewusst,
dass es in der Wüste Pässe gibt,
hätte ich das
nicht auf meine Liste genommen.
Also, das hätten wir.
Rad fahren in einer Wüste, toll.
Vor Manu und Jonny liegen
200 km Fahrt auf Schotterstrassen.
Das Ziel ist Baviaanskloof,
ein riesiges Naturreservat.
* Fröhlicher Popsong
"Bushfire" von Home *
# There's a bushfire
raging outside my house.
# And there's a bushfire
raging inside my life.
# Deep burning anger
has come into my heart.
Nach dieser Tankstelle
kommt nur noch Wildnis.
In Winterthur hat er Kühe gemolken.
Out there it is very scary!
Where you go?
- Baviaanskloof. - Baviaanskloof.
I give you a book of Baviaanskloof.
Enjoy your trip!
I'm on TV! I'll be famous.
So wie es aussieht, ist er neben
Tankwart auch noch Tourist Guide.
Du riechst immer etwas streng.
Bitte benutze das.
Du hast Durchfall, nicht wahr?
Du bist so ein nerviger Typ.
Die nächsten zwei Tagen gibt es weder
einen Laden noch ein Restaurant.
Sondern nur noch Wälder,
Berge und Ruhe.
Ambiente Baviaanskloof.
Die Strassen in der Baviaansklooft
sind so schlecht,
dass man nur mit Vierradantrieb
vorwärtskommt.
Wo sind wir hier gelandet?
Auf dem Campingplatz Bakkrans,
einer der speziellsten im Land.
Okay, ich muss kurz funken.
Fertig Strasse. Wir müssen hier
parkieren und zu Fuss gehen.
Vorfreude: 100 von 100.
(Funkspruch) Höre ich da Sarkasmus?
Die Filmaufnahmen laufen.
Du darfst nicht dreinreden.
Nein, jetzt fahren wir
3 Std. durch wunderschönes Gebiet,
wirklich wunderschönes Gebiet:
Ein "Ooh" folgt einem "Aah" im Auto.
Und es gibt einen Spalt,
die dunkle Ritze von Südafrika.
Besser bekannt als Höhle von Bakkran.
Nein! Das ist cool!
Nein!
- Wow!
Hello everybody! Anybody here?
Hello?
Wow!
(Jonny imitiert unheimliches Echo.)
Jeder von uns
hat sechs Matratzen zur Verfügung.
Das finde ich sehr toll.
Ich käme nicht darauf,
hierher zu kommen,
aber es ist
nicht so schmuddlig wie gedacht.
Ich erwartete eine schmuddlige Ecke,
aber das ist es nicht.
Optisch ist es mega schön.
Und eine Nacht - das geht okay.
Aber ich würde keine Woche
hier campieren wollen.
Schau, eine Käseraffel.
Es hat alles. Es hat wirklich alles.
Das ist eigentlich noch toll.
Wenn der Kameramann sein hässliches
Neonlicht ausschalten würde,
hätten wir
eine wunderbare Atmosphäre. Danke.
Jonny, du kannst schon wieder etwas
von deiner Bucketlist streichen.
Was? Das stimmt doch nicht.
- Doch, hier steht Baviaanskloof.
Stimmt. Es ist wieder anders, als
ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Hattest du das auf der Liste?
Sicher nicht:
"In einem Loch Feuer machen".
Aber diese Region zu sehen?
- Ja, das ist mega schön.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Mir fällt auf dieser Reise sehr auf,
dass nichts so ist,
wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Aber das soll keine Wertung sein.
Das ist nicht
besser oder schlechter.
Aber ich hatte auf meiner Liste, mit
dir an einem Lagerfeuer zu sitzen.
Ich dachte, in der Wüste,
aber in diesem Spalt hier
ist es auch schön.
Mittlerweile sind die beiden
seit fast zwei Wochen unterwegs.
Was uns auf dieser Reise
neu verbindet,
das, was wir bei Weitem
nicht mehr so oft wie früher hatten:
zusammen unterwegs sein,
Sachen und Inspiration erleben.
Und v.a. bei beiden
das Gefühl in Bauch, Herz und Kopf,
jetzt nicht lustig sein zu müssen.
Das ist eine wichtige Erfahrung,
die wir immer wieder
zusammen machen müssen.
Und das als Freunde,
denn sonst sind wir Arbeitskollegen.
Wir treffen uns pro Woche fünfmal,
um zusammen zu arbeiten -
unter mega viel Druck.
Und das ist
ein unheimlicher Unterschied,
am Arsch der Welt
in einer Felsspalte zu grillieren.
Und das ist schon verbindend, ja.
* Besinnliche Flötenklänge *
Ambiente Höhle Nacht.
Das war ein super Erlebnis.
Und Kaffee im Schlafsack -
hatte ich noch nie in meinem Leben.
Es ist immer das Gleiche im Leben:
Wenn man den Mut hat,
die Komfortzone zu verlassen,
das braucht zwar etwas Überwindung,
aber dann wird es meistens
doch noch irgendwie cool,
ausser es hat
mit Erdmännchen zu tun.
Bei mir war es genau umgekehrt.
Gestern bei der Ankunft
war ich vom Anblick begeistert,
aber es fand sein langfädiges Ende
in einer schlaflosen Nacht:
die Geräuschkulisse,
schnarchende Kumpels.
Nein, ich fand
mega schlecht in den Schlaf.
Jetzt bin ich ziemlich zerknittert.
Ich will jetzt packen und abhauen -
möglichst schnell.
* Fröhlicher afrikanischer Gesang *
Heute soll es
richtig abenteuerlich werden.
Mit dem Vierradantrieb
durch die Wildnis der Baviaanskloof.
Das wäre der Plan.
Wir müssen erst
die Karre leerräumen.
Kannst du ... Ah, da ist er ja.
Ausländer mit kaputten Reifen
sind für die Parkwächter Alltag.
Aber hinter dem Tor im Reservat
werde es noch viel schlimmer,
sagen sie.
Offenbar ist das Pipifax -
und schon platzt unser Reifen.
Und jetzt wird es
erst wirklich schlimm.
Nächste Woche geht es ans Lebendige.
Er hat mir an den Sack gegriffen!
Woah!
- Yeah! Nice!
Ich trage mein Herz auf der Zunge.
Das war schon immer so
und wird auch so bleiben.
Manchmal fällt das Herz
aber auch in die Hose.
Das live erlebt zu haben,
das ging mir echt sehr nahe.
Eindeutig!
Nein, ich bin doch nicht studiert.
Wohin denkst du?
"Durch dick und dünn":
Heute in einer Woche geht es weiter
mit der Reise durch Südafrika.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2019